head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smoky Mike in the god king
that's Jeremy boring and Michael nolles
and with your help we will smash our way
onto the Billboard charts let's go for
this debate we got going on from cnr.com
$20,000 raised in 3 hours for legal
defense of man who decapitated satanic
statue in Iowa capital my conscience is
held captive to the word of God not to
bureaucratic degrees and so I acted now
hold on there a minute we have this
tweet from Matt Walsh Matt Walsh of
course threw down the gauntlet and
struck my face with the dueling glove
over my my opinions on Bud Light No
that's totally fine but he has he has an
opinion on this he says a satanic altar
has no right to exist certainly not
inside a government building we are not
bound by our principles to sit by
impotently while our state houses are
turned into platforms for literal devil
worship quite the opposite in fact now
yeah I I I don't like devil worship
and I think the way you go about
stopping something like this is through
procedure and policy and not through
barbarism and so I guess uh the the the
the issue here is Matt Walsh is
defending the idea that this guy knocked
toppled this altar to Satan and Satanism
it's not NE I don't know if it's
actually Satan it's like Satanism the
religion and my attitude is like
dude I I don't see the argument in if
you feel emotionally satisfied with it
it was just because that's the argument
made by the left for taking Jeff Thomas
Jefferson down to be fair Matt Walsh
addresses this addresses this and says
obviously there's a difference between a
revered historical figure who founded
our you know components of our country
and of our government and Satan and I'm
I completely agree and it should be
considered a venerable object which is
legal a legal defin definition for stuff
like that I don't think a satanic
Monument is a venerable object but the
issue I suppose is if we are a nation
has a right no law respecting an
establishment of religion and people are
allowed to worship the way they want to
worship then we either say we do not
have religious iconography in state
houses or we have to accept that there's
going to be wacky religions we don't
like yeah to me I think that the the
former has to be a pro this is always
the issue with the whole public property
uh sort of concept it's like what do you
what do you allow versus what what it is
that you don't which is why I believe
personally all that stuff needs to be um
um limited because you know to your
point Tim you start getting emotional uh
with it and people yeah obviously
there's a difference between Thomas
Jefferson and freaking Satan but you
know that's still in you know to some
people unfortunately that let's say
that's in the eye of the of the beholder
and so to leave it up to for a dispute
for any Joe Blow to say hey when I'm
feeling a certain type of way I get to
do this versus when I don't you know
that's always going to be a problem
which is why I think the public the
public property thing is is just a
fundamental issue and look I'm a realist
at the end of the day so I get it what
Matt Walsh is kind of uh uh where he's
getting at you know look man the game is
not the we we were talking about this in
previous segments Man the game is the
game so um you know when the left when
they want to let's say that they'll be
and break the rules uh to to to mean
whatever it is that they want to mean so
they don't give a crap about what it is
that you um hold tight and true to and
whatever uh monuments it is that you
have if they feel like it's worth them
toppling it they'll use whatever
nonsensical laws perhaps even to justify
their own their own sort of action so I
think fundamentally I get it you know
what I mean it's like hey I'm playing
the game that they playing you know this
is this this is why the American left or
or more historically speaking uh
conquering totalitarians destroy culture
you see this shouldn't even be a debate
in American culture I mean we can get
into the kind of nuance of oh well what
do you would allow in a government
building versus what you don't but if we
had a culture if we had a consistent
culture this wouldn't even be a debate
we wouldn't we wouldn't be talking about
should a Christian Monument stand or
should a historical monument stand that
would be our culture and we would agree
that's our culture whether we agree with
it spiritually that wouldn't even be up
for debate a satanic Monument shouldn't
even be in the debate but because
they've destroyed our culture and we've
got all this infighting now about oh
what should be here what should be there
what's the Nuance of all these laws well
at at some point culture kind of would
overwhelm all of that but because our
culture has been destroyed now we have
to sit here and have a debate of does a
say statue belong in the government
building it's like are you kidding me
but but the question is do you want to
become what you're fighting so I would
just kind of counter that kind of point
if we're if we're going to be doing that
okay let's let's you know isn't that a
winning issue like you can't support the
guy that tears down Satan right right
but no that that's again I get it but in
it that's where I think the left sort of
differs from the quote unquote American
right because they don't care about that
part which is why they're such a a
difficult enemy to fight so while yeah I
don't want to be you and I don't want to
become you it's not going to stop them
from kicking me in the nuts when they
get when they get a chance they have
absolutely no issues bastardizing
whatever power it is that they they they
sort of have again like I was saying
before bending and breaking the rules so
you can go up to him and be like look
man I I don't want to be you you like I
look at you and you're the worst of us
all but in the same respects on the
other of the other hand they're like
well I don't care I am I dirty yeah I I
I the left
I mean you should have everybody
realized this in 2020 or at least you
should have um that should have been a
wakeup call for everybody when the whole
Co thing and the pro like George Floyd
stuff stuff happened when the left
literally the day before all this the
riots and and whatever took place they
were basically saying if you went
outside you were going to kill grandma
and then the next like out of nowhere
the George Floyd situation happens now
everybody's bunched up together and
we're walking the streets and they
didn't we knew they were here democrates
they didn't care that's the thing and
this is what I'm trying to explain to
the to to the to the right in this
country it's like look you are dealing
with an enemy that does not abide by the
same set of Ethics morals whatever it is
that you want to call them that you that
you have if anything they will use it
against you it's like that it's like a
militant like sort of leftist atheist
trying to appeal to God when they'll
they'll you know say whatever against
God you know 10 minutes before they made
their claim or they'll be like well that
would be something Jesus do they do that
stuff because they're trying to
weaponize your own this is why the heads
of those universities when they were
asked about the calls for genocide of
the Jews immediately said well the
Constitution protects they they
routinely defy the principle of free
speech our constitutional protections
and then the moment someone questions
some aborn thing they want to say they
immediately run and hide behind the
Constitution so in other words there is
no Jenna Ellis of the left saying hey
guys are we sure we want to do this I
don't remember anyone any lawyers from
the left saying hey stop tearing down
monuments stop attacking police officers
they don't care no and that's what I'm
saying and I don't really I'm not going
to pretend like I know all the answers
this is what I'm saying that's such a
difficult enemy to to to to combat right
because again it's like I'm going into
it and I'm trying to be ethical with
this but I also have to understand that
you're not playing by those same set of
rules you'll hold me to those standards
if it means that it's advantageous to
you but at the end of the day it's not
anything that you're going to follow do
you think a lot of that is denial though
from the American right cuz you say this
is what I'm trying to get the American
right to understand you think a lot of
it is denial like oh we're not under
attack the Constitution isn't under
threat like there this isn't actually
going on delusion I think is more the
accurate term to what it is it's like I
get it you want to believe that the
world is the way that it it's it's
actually not but for the sanctity of our
or really for our own sanity it's like
we need this to be true it's like what
we talk about whether it be with police
officers whether it be with the uh
Judicial System whatever it may be you
like to think that these people are
better than us they are the best of us
they're not not I mean you can see all
the examples in how they're not if
anything they're the worst of us like I
say with the Congress really being a
band full of absolute criminals but in
order for us to get by in life it's it's
comforting to believe this idea that the
world is something that it's absolutely
not and like I said it's just such a
it's such a difficult enemy to to combat
because they're just not going to play
fair and then they tell you that they
have no issues being like yeah I was a
hypocrite to what I did what I said
yesterday yeah I said we said that you
were going to kill Grandma we told y'all
hell we even arrested some of y'all if
it came down to it but now we're going
to link up and we're going to uh protest
and yeah it's okay in fact they were
using the Medical Institution to try to
justify what it was it is that they were
doing when they were linking up despite
them telling you that this was something
that was criminal when you did it that
shows that they just don't care there
was scientific articles there was
mainlined scientists and the corporate
media saying this is going to help
people this is going to be great for
their because because all of these
people wereing together despite them
yesterday saying you were killing
grandma was I think like a university in
Colorado that was like we found black
lives matter protests actually reduced
the spread of Co unable but the
anti-lockdown protest made the made Co
worse and then there was a video out of
New York where everybody's marching and
the doctors wearing masks are all
clapping cheering but then there's a
photo from DC where people are
protesting lockdowns and nurses were
blocking cars and looking angry these
people are hypocrites and they're insane
yes a combination of the two part of the
issues I got with the the Sanic alter
thing that Matt Walsh is talking about
is that I think what started it all was
that someone came in and quote defaced
the where was it a in Congress somewhere
by putting up the Ten Commandments
technically because you're not supposed
to put up any religious text in that
building so they start someone started
it by putting up the Ten Commandments
now I don't necessarily disagree with
the Ten Commandments and I find that
Satan is probably considerably more evil
relatively in general Society than the
Ten Commandments but it it it seems like
the satanic thing was like a response to
well you put up your religion I'm going
to put up my religion how do you like it
so I don't think maybe so but in in that
regard though you have to ask then is it
even really a religion or is it just
spite probably both technically I don't
know exactly what the what the impetus
was but I mean this this Temple of Satan
the satanic temple is now legally a
religion since I don't know when last 20
years couple years ago or something
couple years maybe like four no actually
like five or six years ago I think so
they're they're technically they got tax
code certification or something could
have been anybody could have been an
Islamic symbol could have been a
Scientology thing they're doing it
response to having the Ten Commandments
in in like the building I guess do you
think they would have done the same
thing if somebody put Muslim scripture
up there like RI musl scripture would
have not have been ripped down oh yeah
yeah I don't think so someone had a
visal response to the satanic imagery no
no no but I mean if the if the satanic
imagery was in response to the 10
commandments no no yeah yeah they
wouldn't put anything up over Muslim
stuff yeah I agree right I agree so I
think I think it's I think it's I think
it's animous towards Christianity is
what I think could have been yeah or
could have just been towards organized
religion in general who knows it's tough
to say who I don't know who did it who
did it and who put up the Ten
Commandments did that ever come out did
both of those people get in trouble cuz
why' they let the my point is I don't
think it is against organized religion
in general because I think we all agree
if it was Muslim literature or scripture
they would not have responded with the
satanic it's just it's an assumption I
don't know it's tough to say I have to
ask the guy I don't necessarily condone
tearing it down but it shouldn't have
been there none of those temples should
none of those things should have been
there Ten Commandments shouldn't have
been there in the I I definitely don't
agree with tearing it down you think it
should have stayed I think it should
have been removed through
procedure like you file a lawsuit and
well technically tearing it down is a
procedure you know right what I mean is
I'm not it's a BLM procedure what
they're trying to do is they're going to
go to normies and say look at what Matt
Walsh says when a guy destroys our
statue and then they pretend they care
about statues being removed they're
going to make a false equivalent
now met is correct they're not the same
thing but I I think what he what what I
would say he's missing here is we're
trying to convince regular people we are
right they are playing this dirty game
where they hold their hand in front of
your face and saying I'm not touching
you I'm not touching you and then when
you swap their hand away they post a
video online saying guy punches peaceful
activists this is what they're doing
every step of the way Matt Walsh uh his
reaction is the desired outcome they
wanted someone to smash the satanic
altar they were hoping and praying
someone would do it well let me just
kind of Switch Lanes on this issue then
for this guy who I believe is running
for congress in Mississippi the guy that
uh smashed the satanic altar he is uh I
I believe so whatever whatever we think
about the the action that he had that
day I I would say as a republican voter
and as as somebody who's looking for
somebody with a with a spine in the
Republican party in Congress I say good
that's the exact type of person I want
in Congress because they're not going to
take any crap and they're actually going
to do the things that Republican voters
have been been wanting their
conservative representation to do
forever so if it was a political stunt I
say smart move good for him my concern
is if it if it inspires people to do it
again and then like I have something on
my lawn and someone comes up and they're
like I don't like it and they smash it
down that's not your lawn they're not
going to nobody's going to do it on your
lawn I mean I guess supposedly but this
was in a government building it was a
big story it was a viral story he knew
he could seize the moment did you see
the guy like five days ago walk in with
a fire extinguisher and extinguish the
manora kind of similar like he didn't
agree with the manura in some way that
that that was brutal and and awful and
wrong that like knocking out a satanic
altar irks me in a procedural kind of
way and like a strategic kind of way
like don't give them the thing to desire
actually going after a legit legitimate
religion which is literally just
lighting candles I'm like that's a dick
move you know I mean polish is very a
very Christian Nation and he looked at
that as a Christian and he didn't like
that culture being in his his Christian
Nation that was that was how he looked
at it and I think regardless of of
whether it's Judaism or Satanism there
should be a calm re a high higher level
reasoned response not a brutal
animalistic response I I reject the the
the ethos and ideology of BLM and the
tactics of the left where they they
stomp around like morons biting and
punching things and I think that we
actually could be ideologically better
men and say here is exactly why this
should not be for my reason stands and
we say okay and we take it down and that
the message we send is that we deal with
things in an orderly fashion yeah I I
think this debate is very important
right now because I I I think we're
we're dealing with a situation where a
lot of the people within the doj and the
FBI want to provoke a certain situation
they want I I think the people on the
right to be angry they are acting in a
very litigious unfair way and with them
now going after journalists we were
talking about this a couple days ago
it's almost as if they're trying to
provoke the people on the right to
overreact so I I I think being calm I
think not overreacting I think being uh
better than the left and not acting
violent and not acting on our emotions
is our strength there are some key uh ke
key things to it that that are
disadvantages but but there's also a lot
of advantages for it as well and I think
we should uh uh stay along those lines
in my own personal opinion I could be
wrong but that's just my initial kind of
knee-jerk reaction to all of this your
logic is kind of different right if I'm
hearing you correctly well yeah because
I I look at it both ways it's like a
strategy thing so while I understand
that there is obviously going to be
instances where it is important to not
necessarily act like let's say your
opponent is going to act I just think
you have to be a little more analytical
than just like hey you're the bad guy
and you're acting in a certain way and I
don't want to be that guy I think you
have to be more strategic with it it's
like look in a in a given instance where
it is going to be advantageous for you
to act a certain way long term you got
to take the game for what it is we can't
be I think us trying to be too
idealistic about it is how they cons how
they got so much ground because we
looked at it like oh we are we're the
more analytical guys right we uh uh we
do things the right way meanwhile the
left kind of comes in stomp it around
flipping tables doing whatever the hell
it is that they that they want and to be
fair it's worthed for them I mean gotten
what it is that they they they wanted so
it's like I believe there's an
appropriate response to where yeah you
don't want to just be a leftist I don't
I don't think any that that doesn't help
uh anybody but in the same respect you
got to understand what the actual game
is and as I always say act accordingly
it doesn't mean act like them it means
do not go into a game that is unfair
trying to play fair because you're going
to lose every single time thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IR
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net